[Musique]
harmonium version symphonique est un
rêve devenu réalité pour serge fiori
extrêmement bas tout le monde va pas on
abat toutes parts a comme un moyen on
danse
c'est fou la fois qu'il faut être
doublement à table s'attaque pas connu
des biens et des baies parce que face
aux pauvres
le projet est ambitieux et ça s'entend
dès la première écoute on a sorti
tambours trompettes mêmes guitares pour
mettre toutes les chansons d'harmonium à
la sauce classique
un travail colossal c'est parce que
c'est un parfait bâton sauf deux camps
semblent voisines mais rémi sella par la
classe ou rien en face
cette réécriture musique à 240 minutes
et signé par le chef d'orchestre simon
leclerc qui a dirigé soixante huit
musiciens de l'orchestré symphonique de
montréal
j'ai été là dedans autour de quatre mois
et demi le premier mois j'ai pas eu une
seule note de musique
j'ai tout simplement écouter du hameau
niyum afin de m'imprégner totalement je
vous remets mon goût seviller
[Musique]
l'idée est venue du producteur nicolas
lemieux qui a imaginé cette version
symphonique sans la voix de serge fiori
on était cadre autour d'un petit tableau
this love by on a quelque chose à propos
je dois faire ton nouveau complet mais
pâte à bois
je veux toujours marabout d'un coup tu
sais ce que je suis menacé par ma voix
soit l'os qui comptera cinq fois les
chansons d'harmonium ont été revisités à
de nombreuses reprises ces dernières
années mais cette fois ci pourrait être
la dernière selon serge fiori sak nou
tout ça bonnes salles en europe d'autres
fins
la porte au nez de la fois l'harmonie sa
feuille
l'album histoire sans paroles harmonium
symphonique sera diffusé dans son
intégralité sur les ondes radio d'ici
musique classique le 6 et le 25 décembre
ici wifi les primes radio-canada
maurienne
[Musique]